[Music]
buy him a drink
hi I'm Sheila hi hi I'm uh I'm Gary
Gonna Get You oh
thank you cheers mate
that was kind of weird
oh not really
I have got to come clean with you I'm
from the future
wait I'm I'm sorry I'm a little confused
so how much do you use the tanning
machine oh no it's not a tan machine
it's a time machine try it it's fun I've
spent the entire week with you this
night seven times in a row
wait what'd you do with the other you
from the past
do you think I'm crazy
but it's really cute okay
have you ever had a night like this ever
in your entire life
I just wanted to change a couple things
to make you more perfect this never
happened with old Gary if you erase the
pain you erase the person what exactly
did you change about me I have this
ability take your pain away it's not
yours to take away Sheila it came from a
good place Gary yeah so did gender
reveal parties
I'm gonna make it work
a real Sophie's Choice kind of decision
now isn't it I love it when you make
that jump what what
[Applause]
[Music]
you didn't want to go somewhere more
meaningful like I don't know like to
kill Hitler well I did take out Smithson
who
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]